you are not trying to just get out we're
not doing that this is not self-defense
okay you're learning things you're doing
my core drillings skill isolation
do you understand so you can't just do
whatever all right if I set up a drill
on the handgun to work on repo
management right you're gonna have to
get that round count kgs going pretty
greatly otherwise you won't be able to
work - and so if you go boom
getting jokes forever booth that you're
not going to like your drill repo
amendment is shocking and boo boo boo
boo boo boo boo do you understand so
when you do something different you're
not doing the skill development this is
the same thing so let's get ourselves in
the first ballpark so the first thing is
is energy is going this way this way
this is very common very common I played
it around and I go inside so we do with
the grip he's pushing I have to have
zero pressure at the grip so that's
where I moved but I move to this corner
that's is over sanctuary pools protected
so I'm not gonna like this
let's just work on this part slightly
[Applause]
and my strike should be able to have
energy in it so you just stick your hand
in there do you think that's an attempt
to silence him you need to know how to
use the percussion so don't reach the
rest
[Music]
[Applause]
drill the hips the ankle the knee stay
in relationship with employer that
brings a foot in to a turn
boom I'm not here moving my foot here
boom out smooth I'm not going into this
pool is happening in this reaching zero
pressure so don't step like this
there's no rotational torque to your
stride this is the round pound on the
back foot to your stride and you haven't
started the rotational orbit you need to
counter rotate within it
so this schools my hips turn on a single
pivot point rounded back foot he gets
about here he's gonna want to turn at me
that's why I go on the inside
then we're just gonna work on that home
why hi Edna scrilla I need the first one
clear I wanna meet in that time so this
is wrong I rarely see Moo's whoa our
faction am i back in his chest you do
like to add a cause in a fall boom boom
boom the more energy on your part I
don't want to be far away from them they
kiss my back
[Music]
fool fool fool
so one rotation to rotation rotation
no boat turning turning hips turning for
me
this software you come up is not strong
this is a huge assumption
okay this hat goes like this Louise you
gotta hear is it outrageous this yeah
which way'd he go then there's my window
that's where that vegetation out this
way this way not this not this
not this he won't say Universal
cultivation I may be here forever
too far
Hey
[Music]
first down push down
watch your money
even my good depression stop hanging she
stops I keep the accelerate we go right
into the elders
[Music]
there is no more anything else you're on
the street no there are two kings why I
don't have to be careful - but - I'm not
hold the baby my money
this is this is the drug this is the
drug whoa you drink all the time we were
doing yesterday what
[Music]
is going to go forward that way that
starts to throw him you see
keep your going forward forward go live
it for under it move okay
here here here sing okay let's go
No when I don't like this you guys are
here
buh-bye head backs into it
so you those of you who are late it's
because you're not turning look at this
relationship the last drill if he was at
that I think that my back should be here
oh the head backs into it
if you did this drill right at your life
you will be on the high point of that
unarmed I have this right this is over
to the side you're going to be in the
armpit area this is the mill when I
rotate and this stays in front of me
watch how these elements where's my head
not right up it's the high point of the
arm
okay let's go